the Trump administration announced last
night that the 2020 US census will
include a question about citizenship
makes sense right it seems perfectly
reasonable for the US government to want
to know how many citizens live in this
country here's how far left immigration
advocates reacted to the news what the
Trump administration is trying to do is
to weaponize the census so that they can
use it to undercount people in
California and other states with high
immigrant population the federal
government including President Trump has
to justify why he would be weakening any
type of census count or census standards
he needs to uphold the rule of law it's
very clear what this administration is
trying to do it they're trying to still
fear in the immigrant community
I love the comment about the rule of law
that's rich and naturally the California
Department of Justice filed a lawsuit
against the Trump administration it's at
least the 27th time the Golden State has
sued the Trump administration including
over daca the travel ban the border wall
pretty much any time the Trump
administration burps they get a lawsuit
by California to debate this census
controversy is California Congressman
Brad Sherman who's a Democrat
congressman first of all I want to say
thank you for joining us we invite
Democrats on pretty much every night and
most declines so thank you very much we
love having a spirited conversation
about these issues okay here's my quick
question first law it's good to be with
you fantastic but first I need to
correct the beginning of your show oh no
no we're not correcting that we're
getting this first and then we're gonna
get to you can cor about correcting me
later but let's keep this focused on
citizenship why are Democrats afraid of
the US government determining how many
illegal immigrants are in the United
States well first of all this census
question has nothing to do with how many
illegal immigrants are in the United
States they don't ask whether you're an
illegal immigrant so there is no attempt
in this to determine that okay we want
to know who is a citizen and the purpose
of this
is clear the purpose of this is to
suppress not only immigrants from
responding but anybody who's got a
cousin who's an immigrant the studies
have shown from the Census Department
last year under Trump administration
that this question will depress
responses this is a two-part approach
first creating credible fear the way the
beginning of your show did in immigrant
communities castigate them call them
rapists and murderers create an
atmosphere the criminals that I talked
about at the beginning of the show is
that what you're doing sir you're child
abusers murderers the fentanyl
traffickers really is that what you want
to come on this show to because I'll
debate that morning noon and night let's
do an hour on El Gordo who trying to
avoid what fed well let's talk about El
Gordo I mean honestly the Democrats just
lose the American people you you are
more worried about illegal immigrants
than the legal residents of your own
communities time and again and now you
don't want us to know how many nonsense
any chance I'll get a word in edgewise
and that's another tactic yes you can
but don't start coming on the show and
saying I want to correct but you said in
the first segment what I said in the
first segment is factual we have a
criminal alien problem in the United
States and your state is a sanctuary
disaster that's the problem go ahead
Laurel can you breathe came on and you
showed that you showed the president
saying that most immigrants especially
from Mexico are rapists and murderers
know that statistically it is do you
tell me where he said most they've said
they're rapists and murderers and some
he listed it at the third category first
category rapists second category murders
and then a footnote to indicate that a
few were good people that's what the
president said but what did the
beginning of your CEO say you put a
picture after picture of terrible
criminals who happen to be people of
color now why don't you
I'll be in the womb you don't want the
truth see I'm here to tell them no I'm
here to tell any chance I can get a word
in edgewise migrant is like a
valedictorian rescuing a puppy or cat
from the tree that's your story my story
is the American victims out there who
you in so many Democrats never pay
attention to and there of course there
are good people who are working why do
you invite me on the show if I'm not
allowed to say anything because I comes
because I will meet you it's falsehood
to stand on this show but go ahead
the falsehood is that immigrants are
disproportionately from their 11 million
people in this country without documents
in your crack staff many pictures of
some who are terrible criminals how do
we know how many are here you have
pretty good estimates where do we go
it's a what we do you can't certainly
send out a questionnaire and find out
how many immigrants there are without
documented country the purpose that is
to destroy the census we have very good
estimators we had look you're talking
about a country that s that has an
intelligence worldwide we certainly can
sound relatively close to determining
how many there are and and look you want
to say 10 to 12 go right ahead
I'm saying 11 you say 10 to 12 pick your
own how many legalize here
I mean we don't know how many that's one
of the points we're making here citizens
versus we certainly can't find out
through the Sen house the purpose of the
the purpose of this census question is
to destroy the census by getting people
not to return their questionnaires the
purpose of the beginning of your show
was to ignore the fact that crime is
committed by all groups every 10 million
people every look you have more crime in
California in than Wyoming because you
have more people in California than
right so every tell the American people
tonight that if you because the
California wants to be sanctuary
fugitive state whatever you want to call
it we have
sacrifice a certain number of Americans
for this utopian idea that borders are
pointless that walls are bad that that
the rule of law when applied to you know
a family crossing the border wants a
better life you can't deport them any
chance I can get away on the altar of
that I just think that's not a great
argument we want law and order across
the board or why do you even need me on
the show it's your show you can just
talk now the fact is if you want less
crime move to the Cayman Islands they
got so few people here there you can go
a whole week without a without a violent
crime the fact is that immigrants or any
group of people if you're gonna have
people in this country there's going
every group of 11 million people commit
some crime and if you had your any
chance I can get a word in here well
then have fewer people there is
difference between illegal and legal do
you not do not note a difference does it
matter i any chance I can get a word in
the fact is there's your show pause the
census has routinely throughout it's
very ask questions about citizenship
status has it not and the Americans
that's not true they stopped in 1950
they stopped about the time I was four
years old and before you were born now
and then the American survey Act that
only that is not used as the official
enumeration the enumeration of this
country is constitutionally required and
getting an accurate count in the
enumeration is more important is
constitutionally more important than
having facts about how many bad bedrooms
there are how many bathrooms are in
every house so that not give a secondary
priority back so you do you think
illegal immigrants should be accounting
for the apportionment of the number of
legislators a state has so in other
words the Constitution says that it does
better scale if they have her be counted
right so your what your sentence is
immigrants are it look at this
citizens when it comes to the
apportionment clause there's a debate
about that in legal circles it's not
determine the Constitution says that the
Supreme Court says that the the Abbott
case reached that conclusion and if you
want to reverse that fine try to pass a
constitutional amendment back the court
and try to reverse the decision federal
government don't the census in an effort
to achieve a constitutional result that
you can't achieve through the court you
have to respond to census so people
aren't going to respond to census it's
another another reason they're breaking
the law you have to respond by look you
don't have enough money to get everybody
to respond to the census you have to
respond to the Sun they're deliberately
underfunding the census and then they
get people to respond to the
questionnaires we'll have you back and I
appreciate you joining us